[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui carrière quelque chose d'habitude et
interviews leaf à notre place oui c'est
ce que j'allais dire aussi y en a bien
compris le message
ça va bah oui bon d'avoir bien ta pose
un problème moteur
[Rires]
merci
le crès la note reçue qui prend des
photos le ouf
un film c'est bien de répéter un premier
rendez vous réussi pour toi ces dîners
dans un super resto romantique et baiser
sur le front
vous ne dites jamais où ils premier ça
sur le front we will i am et oui le
premier soir un petit baiser sur le
front des enquêtes ou une conversation
génial suivi d'un orgasme c'est quand
même un minimum tu vas faire là-bas la
prochaine fois que tu vaux chose j'ai
envie de dire les deux mon général c'est
vrai que les coquilles qui avait su
qu'on pouvait la faire celle là alors
d'abord non mais là je pense que toi tu
es le gai écoute à l'âge que j'ai
maintenant je dirais deux à wuala ouais
ça y est tu te disais qu on n'a qu'une
vie continue comme le dîner c'est d'un
ringard
deuxième question pour vous les super
riches de quoi le shibari ce que chypre
avait alors le [ __ ] d'âge
[Applaudissements]
le shibari ce bien des questions sur
lesquelles shinari pour vous le suivrez
le shibari stello le menu à 3 du resto
japonais du quartier ouais ou bien une
pratique japonaise que vous mourrez
d'envy d'essayer sauf que encore s'il ya
rupture de stock sur les cordes mais on
peut essayer son plateau tous les trois
si vous voulez pourquoi pourquoi vous
mettez toujours dans l'histoire
et j'aime ça que tellement c'est gros
cul mais j'applaudis manger avec des
oiseaux non non je vais dire 2 6 arrêts
c'est un art japonais qui consiste à
attacher
oui georges était une bonne réponse du
tas de tâches avec des foulards ou s'ils
préfèrent la toile c'est lui c'est quoi
alors certes non c'est des foulards on
s'attache avec des foulards c'est la
sarre et corps assez d'accord avec des
couleurs toujours que tu vois les
personnes que vous n'avez jamais encore
testé la drague sur tender les sex toys
ou une longue période d'abstinence la
drac sur tinner à la tension oui
ah ouais j'habitais battant caen quand
tu es un peu connu ce sort kinder
bonjour je suis ebinto mag avec un truc
pour les gens comme sûrs je sais mais en
même temps la célébrité
le fait d'être connu sa fausse tout leur
apport dans la vraie vie dans les
relations amoureuses particulièrement
alors sur tinner j'imagine même pas
alors que les sex toys
mais ma fille regarde référé parce
qu'elle m'a dit je te préviens tu vas
chez hanouna mais s'il te plaît tu parle
pas de moi lola à 18 ans oui mais même
alors pas le mois lui a donné son nom
son âge
c'est vrai dans la lah 18 ans quand
elles habitent autres percussions invité
à un dîner qui est le plus susceptible
de vous séduire
un laurent baffie qui vous met de
travers mais qui vous l'espérez vous va
vous tirer les cheveux avant la fin de
la soirée suivante a changé toit voisin
de table un peu relou mais qui partagent
votre passion pour les chats comme vous
il en est deux je suis jamais sortie
avec quelqu'un de connu
ça risque pas de m'arriver c'est je
fréquente pas les gens connus ce qui est
de ne pas là moi tu connais ma vie en
corse et du tout simple tu me vois
arriver aux sports donc c'est pas mon
truc mais la réponse doit me plaisait
pas donc oui parce qu'on fait du sport
lll et d'île rousse
[Musique]
je cherche un travail
des bouquins merci à kara morgan